- Hey guys.
Everybody on the VIP continuing
the original content theme which
I think has been really
driving my email newsletter
so thanks for watching.
Thanks for listening.
And here's your little
exclusive piece of content:
Anchor, a new audio
social network app,
has made some noise this week.
I've been enjoying it.
It is super interesting.
Here it is.
A lot of people started
to follow me which is fun.
Just kinda put out
memos to the world.
Voiced Twitter I think is
not super inappropriate.
Something I've been
watching and hoping to
happen for a long time.
I like voice.
But more importantly here's
what I wanted to talk about.
Much like I'm watching I'm
watching everybody on Snapchat
now sell $300 e-books or change
their profiles to Snapchat QR
codes or all the other things--
(phone dings)
It keeps doing that.
One of things that I have
noticed in Facebook and in
Twitter, Facebook fan pages,
Twitter, Tumblr, Instagram,
Snapchat, MusicAlly and now the
potential in Anchor the upside
of being an early
mover, Meerkat.
I've seen Bryant Social,
all these social people.
Meerkat, Periscope.
The advantage of being the first
users on a new platform and
being loud and proud and using
your other social networks to
bring awareness to you being
on there, your newsletters your
other means word-of-mouth, email
however you want to go about it
and then really learning the
craft, putting out content,
being part of the community,
following other people,
engaging with them,
responding to them.
That is a blueprint that works.
Now for every Instagram there
is a Plurk, there is a SocialCam
but when I look at the first 10
or 15 pioneers on Vine
or the first 500
on Instagram
or the first hundred
on MusicAlly
there's such a disproportionate
advantage to being an early
influencer personality on one
of these platforms that you can
miss eight times in a row and
that ninth one will pay out
the ROI of all your efforts and
tribulations if you have enough
talent in the communication
of the medium that you choose.
If you are scared of video and
you're not a great writer but
you can talk a little Anchor if
it clicks and goes and right now
it is so far from that I
don't predict it will.
I don't even think it will.
But if it does,
the punchline of this video is
I do not think,
yeah, actually I'll
go a different way.
I believe it is in your best
vested interest on every Peach
and every Anchor to move fast to
be part of the community and to
try and build your brand in the
first 60 days on the platform
because if one of 'em does
become Twitter or
Pinterest or
Vine it will change your life.